Oui... Le mec fait son bilan de l'année fin janvier et ça ne choque personne
Le mec part en couille total. Il veut quoi, il veut perdre tous ses abonnés ?
Bravo bel exemple Cyprien !
Un peu de ponctualité merde
Je vais revenir sur tout ce que j'ai fait pendant l'année 2017 parce que vous avez loupé plein de trucs
Et désolé si je m'y prends vraiment tard, c'est parce que là j'ai eu pas mal de boulot sur un très gros projet
Et ça je vous en parle à la fin de la vidéo
Le début de l'année 2017 a commencé super fort avec ma vidéo pour les 10 millions d'abonnés
C'est un tour du monde où je vais rencontrer des gens un petit peu partout sur la planète terre
C'est la vidéo la plus importante de ma chaîne
Beaucoup de rencontres, beaucoup de voyages, beaucoup de fatigue
Et il y a surtout le trophée des 10 millions d'abonnés
Je suis très content d'avoir ça et petite anecdote : Le trophée que vous voyez à la fin de la vidéo de Norman
C'est le mien. Voilà.
En parallèle de ma vidéo des 10 millions d'abonnés j'ai travaillé sur mon court métrage qui s'appelle "Le déménagement"
Qui parle d'une thématique qui m'est très très proche
C'est le fait de se lancer, de faire des choix risqués
Et j'envois énormément d'amour aux Parasites qui ont réalisés ce court métrage
Et à Slimane Baptiste qui a fait mon duo
"On fait le fiche : KEV GAD TOUT EST POSSIBLE"
Après le court métrage j'ai lancé un nouveau concept sur ma chaîne YouTube qui sont les quizz
Voilà, c'est des petites émissions avec des guest
sur les thématiques d'internet et de YouTube
Squeezie : "Ahah.. attends mais y'a un blem' là"
Le Grand JD : "Ya un complot"
C'était l'éclate de faire ça, c'était trop marrant de faire une sorte de petite émission un peu façon burger quiz
Et si vous en voulez d'autres pour cette année 2018, n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les commentaires
Après ça j'ai réalisé mon sketch : "Si le président était Youtuber"
Et ce sketch à la particularité d'avoir été tourné devant la même feuille de décors, je m'explique :
Le champ et le contre champ on été tournés en fait au même endroit
On a juste inversé les regards, on a rajouté un petit drapeau
Et ensuite on a inversé l'image, et on a l'impression que c'est des gens qui se parlent dans une même pièce
C'est la petite astuce de professeurs Cyprien voilà...
Puis ma vidéo sur "Les vieux et la technologie 2" le retour
Parce que j'adore les vieux, j'adore la technologie
Avec une séquence que j'ai beaucoup aimé faire sur les vieux qui appelle le service après-vente pour leur box
"Est-ce que votre câble d'alimentation est bien branché ?"
Quelques jours après je sors la mise à jour finale de mon jeu mobile gratuit : "Le Nope Quiz"
Voilà c'est 100 questions débiles
Mais ça a rendu fou des gens, les gens on cassés leur téléphone
"Ohhhhhh !"
Cyprien : "Il a compris du premier coup !"
Plusieurs millions de téléchargements et surtout il a été dans le top 10 des jeux gratuits sur l'App Store
Donc je suis très content
Ma BD "Roger et ses humains" à été traduite en Anglais
"Roger and his humans"
C'est le titre en anglais voilà je... trouve ça un peu cool
Après ça ma vidéo sur "Les gens sur internet"
"Si t'as pas d'ami vas sur Twitter"
Et c'est ma 100ème vidéo sur ma chaîne
Voilà c'est un peu un symbole
Et c'est 10 fois moins que Squeezie
Faut peut-être que j'y aille un peu plus que ça...
On arrive à l'été 2017 et là sortent 2 très gros projets
Ça faisait longtemps que je bossais dessus
Des mois d'écriture et de préparation
D'abord ma mini série avec Natou et Norman qui s'appelle "Presque Adulte"
Qui est sortie sur TF1 et sur YouTube
Et ma série audio "l’Épopée Temporel"
J'en ai déjà parlé sur ma chaîne, de ces 2 projets donc ne pas revenir dessus
Mais en tout cas je voulais juste vous remercier
De continuer à regarder les projets qui sont assez différents de ce qu'on peut voir sur la chaîne YouTube
De continuer à être curieux, merci à vous
Et vous pouvez les regarder sur YouTube dès à présent si c'est pas déjà fait
On arrive aux 11 millions d'abonnés
Pour fêter ça j'ai ramené des petits objets farfelus du Japon
Avec un énorme travail d'investigations et de recherches sur les objets les plus perchés de l'histoire de l'objet perché
J'ai farfouillé partout à Tokyo pour vous trouvez ça
Et on a testé tout ça avec Norman et Squeeze donc merci à eux
A la fin de l'été je pars 24 heures à New York pour Samsung
Alors ça fait très bizarre de changer de continent juste pour une journée
Voilà c'est pas mal de décalage un peu chelou mais j'ai bien profité de la ville
Et vous pouvez voir la vidéo sur ma page Facebook
Avec Lucas on a participé à l'émission Fort Boyard
Voilà c'était ma 2ème fois, je pense avoir fait la séquence la plus ridicule de l'histoire
Avec moi qui tiens pas 1/2 seconde sur un vélo
Regardez je suis là
J'ai disparu
Ouai moquez vous ! Bien, sympa les gars !
On arrive à la rentrée et ça commence très fort
Avec l'avant première de la fin de l’Épopée temporelle dans un cinéma
Donc c'était très classe, merci à tous ceux qui sont venus
J'ai bossé en scred pour aussi relancer ma marque Narmol
Voilà avec plein de nouveaux produits
Ceci par exemple
Vous avez été très très nombreux à l'avoir demandée : On a fait "Les réunions 3"
Pour l'épisode d'avant, en Guest on a eu Danny Boon qui était super sympa
Et en 2017 on a eu Denis Brogniart qui à été adorable !
C'est mon épisode préféré des réunions
On a tellement ri, super souvenirs
J'ai rencontré Alain Chabat
Voilà c'est un moment important dans ma vie parce que c'est un petit peu ma référence en humour
Et je crois que ça se voit à mon visage
On arrive à la fin de l'année 2017 avec Lucas on vous a préparé un clip sur nos 10 jeux préférés de l'année
Et en même temps pendant l'année j'ai passé une tête chez les potes sur plein de chaînes YouTube
Notamment sur la chaîne de Julien Pestel, de Akim Omiri, Tutube, le clip Overwatch de Lucas,
What The Fuck France, Cocovoit,
Multiprise,
Cyprien : "Puis je monte dans ma Twingoo, car la route n'a pas de..."
"Mais putin ! Mais comment ça ?!"
Vous m'avez envoyé plein de Fan Art magnifiques, merci beaucoup
Ça a égaillé toute cette année
Et maintenant parlons de mon prochain gros projet
Qui explique pourquoi je suis en retard sur ce bilan de l'année
Depuis plusieurs mois je travaille sur mon prochain court-métrage qui s'appelle "Lunaire"
On vient de terminer le tournage, ça s'est super bien passé c'était mortel
Je suis très content d'avoir partagé ça avec des comédiens top, avec Raphaël des cracs à la réalisation
C'est un projet avec des thématiques qui sont très personnelles, c'est pour ça que ce court métrage est très important pour moi
Ca sort en février donc j'espère que ça va vous plaire et que vous allez répondre présent
Merci beaucoup pour cette année 2017 de m'avoir accompagné dans tous ces projets farfelus
Parce qu'y s'est passé plein de choses sur ma chaîne et ailleurs
Je vous prépare pas mal de choses pour l'année 2018 à commencé par mon prochain court-métrage
Et je vous dis à très vite !